these are just a few of the tech
companies whose share prices have fallen
in 2022
and here's a chart of the percentage
change in the tech heavy nasdaq compared
to broader indexes while stocks are down
in general the tech industry is having
an especially hard time and in april and
may a wave of layoffs and hiring freezes
hit the sector the story of what's
happening with tech is not just a story
about this year or even the last year
itself it's really a story about what's
been happening over the past decade
while other sectors have faced declines
here's why the tech industry is having a
record downturn after years of growth
ten years ago the tech industry was
ready to grow the u.s was still
recovering from the great recession and
interest rates were hovering near zero
the federal reserve is using its
monetary policy tools to promote a more
robust recovery so low interest rates
they're good for tech stocks uh lower
yields make it really really easy to
you know
increase the appeal of the future
earnings that a lot of these tech stocks
will have in 2012 and 2013 tech players
like facebook and twitter went public
and advancements like mobile and cloud
technology helped drive profits for many
companies and fueled growth in the
sector
let's go back to that nasdaq chart we
can see how the tech industry steadily
grew over the decade as money poured in
outpacing growth in other industries
as revenue grew companies also expanded
their workforces for example facebook
added about 40 000 employees to the
company between 2012 and 2019. by the
end of that year tech was at the
forefront of the stock market with a
bull run being driven by companies like
apple and microsoft 2010s were really
the decade of disruption for a lot of
these tech stocks we really started to
you know be on our phones longer we
started going on social media and all
these factors combined really really
increased the allure of tech stocks and
investors wanted a piece of it low
interest rates and increased smartphone
use were vital contributors to growth
those two factors combined together
really made it easy to you know just
sort of go into the tech trade and
really led to the valuations of a lot of
these tech companies to become really
inflated really lofty then 2020 hit the
breaking news stay at home that is the
order tonight from four state governors
stocks across the board initially took a
plunge as stay-at-home orders and
lockdowns rippled across the world
with more people stuck at home the tech
industry was set up to capitalize on
demand when the pandemic first started
we had all these lockdowns we had travel
restrictions and people were stuck at
home so what do you do when you're stuck
at home you go online and you binge
watch shows on netflix you want to talk
to your friends you go to zoom at the
same time washington enacted a massive
stimulus plan the government sent out
more than 150 million stimulus checks
and the fed made plans to lend billions
of dollars across markets we have held
our policy rate near zero since
mid-march and have stated that we will
keep it there until we are confident
that the economy has weathered recent
events and is on track to achieve our
maximum employment and price stability
goals the federal reserve slashed
interest rates and they were
historically ultra low and that made it
also very very easy for a lot of these
tech companies to take on cash to take
on you know take to borrow more money
and lower their borrowing costs so yeah
that all together really helped tech
stocks get to the levels they were at in
2020 and 2021. as stimulus flooded the
economy market cap prices for tech
leaders like amazon apple and meta
reached new records some companies
significantly grew their workforces to
meet rising demand announcing increased
hiring during earnings calls to
shareholders we ended the quarter with
over 71 900 full-time employees up 23
compared to last year we finished the
quarter with nearly 3 800 employees up
134 year-over-year but growing
valuations flash a warning sign to some
analysts who speculated that companies
might not be able to keep up with the
exploding growth
inflation was beginning to take center
stage we had federal reserve chair
jerome powell come in and say that yeah
okay we're now going to start thinking
about raising rates to fight inflation
because it seems like it isn't temporary
anymore high inflation is is a is a
severe threat to the achievement of
maximum employment into achieving a long
expansion that can give us that and
that's an investor's absolutely freaking
out panicking about these tech companies
share prices for small tech companies
and giants alike started to slip
while inflation supply chain issues and
the war in ukraine were impacting
businesses around the world tech was
being faced with other unique challenges
ad revenue which social media companies
like snap twitter and facebook rely on
has taken a hit as inflation led
companies to spend less on advertising
and apple introduced a privacy feature
last year that restricts user tracking
which means that sites have a harder
time targeting ads to users companies
now had to redesign their ad targeting
and tracking tools to comply with the
new rules and by doing so lost business
meta estimated that apple's ad tracking
changes would cost the company 10
billion dollars this year another issue
that caused earnings to take a tumble is
changing consumer behaviors so
previously we were all at home ordering
stuff online again and now we're
shifting back and going back in person
we're going to restaurants we're going
to stores companies are looking to cut
costs having expanded when growth was
booming in a shareholder meeting meta
said that given the resulting revenue
head headwinds we have adjusted our
plans for hiring an expense growth this
year carvana ceo said in an email that
they would cut around 2 500 workers and
robin hood said in a shareholder meeting
on their increased hiring that at the
time we thought that this was right to
keep up with the pace of the business
but it also led to some inefficiency
some redundant roles
stocks have dropped quickly amid poor
earnings results and the slowdown in
growth
now some investors are bailing on
volatile tech stocks as interest rates
rise so tech companies also include some
of the most speculative companies in the
market and riskier ones as well so it
makes it really really hard for you to
justify owning something that's not
going to be profitable for a long time
in the future to come it's unclear where
the market might go from here analysts
and investors right now remain divided
about whether this slowdown is going to
be temporary or permanent and not all
tech companies have been hit as hard ibm
and citrix have both continued to
outperform the declining market but with
the federal reserve expected to steeply
raise interest rates analysts say tech
stocks will continue to suffer